we're going to begin this hour with a
story that you'll see only on CBS
mornings and we love when that happens
it's an effort to undercover one of the
dark to uncover rather one of the
darkest and most troubling secrets of
Britain's upper class King Charles has
approved an inquiry into the Royal
Family's ties to slavery a history he
has been pressured to apologize for
Holly Williams spoke with one of the
king's cousins leading a separate effort
to show how other prominent families
were connected to the slave trade she
joins us now from Buckingham Palace
Holly good morning to you
good morning Gail there are several
British families leading this campaign
shining a light on this country's deep
involvement in slavery but one family
with historical connections to slavery
that is not taking part is the family
that lives here inside Buckingham Palace
so this is 18th century this is uh this
is 18th century the house the Earl of
Harewood is a British Aristocrat and
Harewood house is his ancestral home now
open to the public it makes Downton
Abbey look like a shack but it was all
built with the prophets of slavery how
'd it feel about this being part of your
family history I'm ashamed that they
people behaved in that way that my
ancestors have behaved in that way we're
accountable for that Legacy today uh all
portraits of various ancestors the
Earl's forebears enrich themselves with
sugar plantations in Jamaica and
Barbados in which enslaved Africans
toiled when Britain finally outlawed
slavery in its colonies in 1834 like
other slave owners they were compensated
by the government around three million
dollars in today's money and the slaves
themselves who had been freed were they
compensated the slaves who were freed
received nothing and what you can see
down there now the Earls behind the
campaign calling for other families that
benefited from slavery to come clean and
use their wealth to benefit the
descendants of those who were trafficked
he calls it reparative justice it's
something that people have been very
much into denial about structure under
the carpet pretended it hadn't happened
why
guilt shame
it's very difficult to put a finger on I
don't I don't know I don't really I
don't understand it the the
dehumanization
you you can't compensate for that but we
can all work together toward doing what
we can so you know we may not Joy
Williams is a descendant of British
owned slaves in Jamaica he now leads
historical tours exposing how this
country profited from slavery but many
mansions were built from this Prophet
From Slavery yes
British slave Traders traffic nearly
three and a half million Africans to the
Americas I can say hand on heart that
there are legacies of transatlantic
trade which hold me and many people back
from being seen as in some cases as
human beings when you talk to some
British people
they talk as if slavery is something
that happened in America not here that's
right why is that
um because of Education you mean lack of
education and luck I do yes
another British family with historical
links to slavery is the royal family
historians say it's impossible to
calculate exactly how much wealth the
monarchy generated from Human
Trafficking but some kings and queens
were directly involved
Buckingham Palace announced this month
that it's cooperating with an
independent investigation into the
monarchy's connections to slavery King
Charles and Prince William have both
expressed their Sadness the appalling
atrocity of slavery forever stains our
history
I want to express my profound sorrow but
they've stopped short of an apology an
official visit to Jamaica last year by
William and Kate Drew demonstrations
demanding reparations and criticism that
it looked like a throwback to
colonialism the Earl is related to the
Royals a great grandson of King George V
and a second cousin of King Charles
should they be leading the way
we should all be doing more shouldn't we
uh yeah you can never do you can never
do enough uh and it's not something
that's ever going to go away if you
could talk to King Charles directly
about this issue what would you say to
him uh it's a bit late in the day
so I think some spearheading to get us
ahead
of where we should be rather than behind
Joe Williams and the Earl of hair Ward
have actually worked together on
projects to educate the British public
about this country's historical
involvement in slavery and now the Earl
is adding to his art collection
commissioning new portraits of black
British Community leaders to hang beside
his ancestors Gail all right that's a
positive sign thank you very much Holly
Williams reporting from Buckingham
Palace it's one of those things where
sometimes you need to have the
uncomfortable conversations to get it
out there put it in the light I think
that that's very important to do that
yeah I do I believe that having
education on issues like this is
important I do too don't forget you
learn about the past regardless of what
side of the atrocities your bloodline
existed on I think it's important to
learn about where we've been so we don't
repeat those things in the future well
said not like what Joe said we should
all be doing more we could all be doing
better he's right